I'm going to connect the chat to that again.
There we go.
All right, so make sure you chat in your questions.
If you have them, we're live.
A lot of people send in questions.
And like I always remind everybody
you can go to holistichealthour.com,
holistichealthour.com where you can send in your questions,
like everybody else has done.
But certainly, chat in your questions.
And we'll try to get to them.
So let's jump in with some questions.
Doing this from home today, a little hot,
and tired just came in from doing some gardening.
That is our passion, is to garden.
So let's get to your questions.
OK, how to stop protein urea?
So protein urea is when you have protein in your urine.
And it tends to be a chronic issue.
I wouldn't even say it's a condition
because it's typically benign.
It's not usually an issue whatsoever
that you need to worry about.
If that was my only clinical finding, did I have any symptoms?
Did I have any other blood work changes?
And remember, when you look at blood work,
so this would be a urine sample that they wouldn't find that.
But if you look at blood work, there
are different parameters that you want to look at.
So I have a video on this that details this on our website.
So you can find a lot of information
on our website, cuntersclinic.com
if you go to the blog, or well over 1,000 blog posts.
Most of them have videos tied to them.
They'll be explaining different things.
But when you look at blood work, there's
a difference between lab ranges and functional ranges.
So you might be normal.
Your doctor may have said, everything's normal.
I tested your blood.
Everything looks normal.
Everything's good to go.
But you're outside of a functional range.
So the only way to know what that is,
I suppose you could Google functional ranges,
but to find a functional medical doctor or practitioner,
like ourselves, that can look at your blood
from a different perspective.
So if all my blood work was within neural ranges,
I had no symptoms, no other signs of issues,
no other objective findings.
And by only objective finding was high levels
approaching in my urine, I wouldn't even consider it.
There's probably some genetic factor that goes along with it.
But I would look at the big picture,
so you don't just look at one test.
So if that was the only thing I had going on,
I wouldn't be concerned about it.
Next question.
Hi, I'm immunosuppressed from Lyme,
combined with an autoimmune gene, even though my Lyme
is in remission.
I spent my life playing whack-a-bowl with herbs,
essential oils, professional wholeopathics, whole
and organic diet, now more restrictive that's
caused me to lose muscle mass for a specific super biofilm
manufacturing pathogen, home procedures for parasite
reduction, now three times a week for flourishing
protozoa, detox and et cetera.
So that's a common initial subjective findings
of somebody who's been diagnosed with chronic mold
or chronic Lyme disease.
They just spend all over there doing a lot of different things.
They've played whack-a-bowl.
I like that terminology that purpose is used
with herbs and supplements and all this kind of stuff.
So their question is, it's been years.
My financial resources are depleted and crisper.
So if you don't know what crisper is,
that's genetic, engineering, a person's genes.
Doesn't seem to be an option at this time.
So there's a lot of research going on with crisper.
A lot of people think it's extremely dangerous.
Some people think it could be a miracle medicine
of the future, but that's for another time.
It's been degrading over time.
So I haven't felt well in years.
Has this truly a game of whack-a-bowl to stay alive?
Do you have any advice regarding repairing
my immune system and stopping the dendritic cell damage
or where to turn?
So dendritic cells are immature white blood cells
that will change into whatever's needed at the time
if there is a local infection.
So I would recommend getting on our autoimmune course,
honestly.
I certainly can't say, oh, just take this
and this is going to be a miracle cure if I said that.
You should probably not listen to me
because there is no such thing.
And people sometimes get mad when they're on calls
like this and they want us to, you know,
you're just like this one magic supplement
away from curing all your problems.
Sometimes people are looking for that.
I don't take this person as looking for that.
But the truth is you got to learn how to handle
if you truly do have an autoimmune disease,
which is extremely common with people
that have had chronic Lyme or chronic mold
or chronic health conditions.
You know, for more than a couple of years,
you have to investigate, do I have an autoimmune disease?
And then you treat, everything's out the window,
you have to treat everything differently.
So if you're using herbs, you're using essential oils,
and even sometimes heliopathics
can stimulate an immune response.
And if you stimulate an immune response,
and you have antibodies against self tissue,
you have an autoimmune disease,
you're going to kill that which you have antibodies against,
meaning you're going to kill your body.
So you're going to have like a Herk's type reaction,
but it's not really a Herk's type reaction.
It is self-destruction.
So it's damaged to the tissue that you have antibodies against.
So investigating that would be my concern.
So if you call to our office,
if you did a case review with me,
I'd say we need to do some autoimmune testing.
Even if you had some in the past,
autoimmune diseases have three phases to them.
So it could be in a very, very early stage,
not even to the latent phase,
where it doesn't even show antibodies to self tissue anymore.
So a person, I've had people come in and say,
well, I did antibody testing three years ago
that conditions got worse,
then we run antibody tests and they show
antibodies or thyroid antibodies or rheumatoid antibodies,
or there are a lot of antibodies,
and these are very serious conditions
and you have to treat them completely different.
Once you have antibodies to self tissue,
your whole treatment procedure has to change completely.
So you cannot be using any immune stimulants
in herbs, vitamins, et cetera.
So you have to be very careful at what to do.
I'd suggest, you know, on the course,
you can go to codersclinic.com
and from codersclinic.com on the top, you'll see courses.
The chronic disease autoimmune course is what I would suggest.
And I'm not just trying to sell stuff,
it's 50 bucks to take the course and it's got dozens
and dozens and dozens of videos and education in it.
So we have doctors that are taking the courses.
They're very beneficial.
Okay, what is the benefit of grounding?
Should I use a grounding sheet?
Well, that's an interesting question
because I have a grounding sheet right here.
So first of all, most people know what grounding is.
I remember talking about grounding 10 years ago or so
and everybody's like, what are you talking about grounding?
Most people have heard what grounding is.
So what grounding is basically helping discharge positive
ions off your body.
That's basically what grounding is.
You know, we live in a world where there's,
you know, how can I turn out a radio with a little antenna?
And I can get all these different stations
because there's radio waves going through us right now.
Does that damage our body?
I don't know.
Does it add a charge to our body?
Yeah, I think so.
I'm sitting in front of a computer screen.
If you're watching me, you're sitting in front of a computer screen
or your telephone, those are EMFs.
Those are charged.
These are electrical frequencies.
They're electrical charge.
And these electrical charge stay on our body
and in our cells on our surface of our tissue, our skin.
And they need to discharge.
So grounding is walking outside in your feet
and touching the ground and you're discharging
those positively charged protons.
The earth is balanced in its electrical charge
and it can definitely give away some electrons
to balance you out.
And that's what ground meat is.
That's a benefit of, you know, having animals
that are walking around with four feet on the ground.
And you go and pet the animal.
You're basically discharging your positively charged EMFs
to the person, to the dog, to the horse, to the cat,
whatever it is.
That's the benefit of pets.
So especially in cold areas and cold climates,
how do you ground them?
Look, a walk around outside in January in my bare feet.
Well, some people do, but I don't think I will.
Well, you could use ground-eat instruments.
Your house is grounded.
Hopefully, unless you live in an old house
and you're electrical outlets are grounded.
We have a fact that you're here.
We have a little testing device.
So in our grounding, we sell, we have the little testing devices
to make sure your, it's our ground-eat,
because if you plug this sheet into it out
and it's not grounded, it's not going to work.
It's not going to do anything.
So the idea is in grounding, using a grounding sheet
or a grounding mat or something like that,
you are, you are plugging it into a grounded outlet,
the ground, the third crawl of a grounded outlet.
That goes back for via a copper wire
back to your electrical box.
And then it connects to a main ground bar
that that's connected to a heavier cable, copper cable
that goes outside and connects to the ground.
So you're basically grounded like walking outside,
but using your grounding of your electrical and your house.
Now, if your house is older, you don't have any three-prone outlets
or you use a device like this and none of your three-prone
healths that are actually connected correctly
are grounded, not grounded.
You may need to call an electrician first
and make sure that that is done.
But you can easily check it with this.
If you don't buy a grounding sheet for us,
you could buy one of these at your local hardware store
for less than $10 or get about Amazon.
It just checks if your outlets are grounded.
And then a grounding sheet is a material that
has little wires in it, basically.
That then this snaps on to a cable that connects
to that third crawl of a grounded outlet.
And that's how you get grounded.
So the benefit of using a grounding sheet
is you're basically grounded yourself all night.
It's hugely beneficial.
So our grounding sheets that we have made specifically
for us are half sheets.
So they only go on the lower half of the bed.
Well, why is that?
Because there's a whole bunch of grounding sheets out
these days that are full sheets that cover your full mattress.
It isn't that better.
Well, yes and no.
So when we have patients that are using a rife machine,
using rife technology, are trying to get good frequencies
in them, we don't want those good frequencies
to just disperse through the grounding sheet
back to the ground outside through your wiring.
So I only tell people to only put it
on the bottom half of their bed.
It's like you don't need to, when you go outside to ground,
you just stand in your bare feet.
You're discharging those positive charged protons.
You don't need to go hung up the ground.
So you just need a part of you touching that grounding sheet
that's going to help disperse those negative charges.
So grounding is great.
I tell you there's thousands of testimonials
of people that have had arthritis issues to migrate issues
to whatever you name it.
It could have to do with the frequencies
that you're picking up, all these negative EMFs
that you're picking up.
I mean, people think of EMFs is, oh, they can cause cancer.
They can cause brain cancer.
They can cause all sorts of ill health.
So grounding yourself is really beneficial.
Maybe it's one of the reasons why I love to guard it.
A lot of people love to guard it.
They just like to get their hands dirty.
Will you grounding yourself?
That's why you feel calmer when you guard it, usually.
Maybe not this time of year.
You feel agrier sometimes, you know, too much to do.
But that's another story.
OK, next question.
Hi.
Any suggested help for chronic diarrhea
beating often starting several times daily
and lasting for several sequential days
and sometimes weeks at times, a few days break
and then start again for a lengthy time period.
And while the diarrhea is occurring,
what are possibly the nutritional deficiencies
that it may cause?
Thank you.
So you could say, oh, what's the health with chronic diarrhea?
Well, first again, with anything, you have a symptom.
You have a sign objectifying this symptom
that you're experiencing.
You've got to find out why.
So why do you have this?
What is the reason?
I would do a stool test.
So I would do a cup of heads of stool analysis.
That would be a first step.
You have to find out if you have parasites,
you have to find out if you have H. Pylori,
which is a bacterial infection, very, very common.
Your microbiota might be totally messed up
just from the diarrhea itself.
It's going to mess it up.
What other deficiencies could you have with this?
Well, anything because if you don't keep it fooded,
you log it up to absorb your nutrients.
You could be deficient in all sorts of nutrients.
Certainly, you could be deficient in fluid in water.
So you could have dehydration type symptoms too.
You've got to get to the bottom of this.
This is not normal.
This is not healthy.
It's not good.
Getting a cup of heads of food stool sample test
is what I would start with.
I don't know who asked this question,
but what will work with us?
You need to schedule a case review
and then you could order that.
We can order that test.
You've got to get to the reason why with anything
you've got going on.
You want to find out why.
You don't want to just, oh, we'll just start taking this.
So we'll just start doing this.
So we're going to start doing this
because then you could actually mask the problem.
That's not good.
So that's the problem I have with so many medications.
So we're just going to start taking a modium
because I have chronic diarrhea.
We have chronic diarrhea for a reason.
So your body's trying to expel something.
What is the abnormality going on?
Could be something as simple as a stucleosecal valve
to something as bad as complete imbalance
and got microbiota, parasitic function, H. Pylori,
other bacterial involvement.
You've got to get to the root of this and fix this.
Could be something as serious as cancer or something too.
So it's not something just to,
I think it's a mistake just to mask symptoms.
Whether you use herbs to mask symptoms,
vitamins to mask symptoms, or using a medication.
What difference are you doing?
You're still masking the symptoms
or doing it in a natural way.
Okay, it's just as bad.
So it's just as wrong to use natural medicine the wrong way
as it is to use medicine the wrong way.
Why do you recommend that cancer patients should eat meat?
I thought we should all be vegan.
Well, no, I don't think we should all be vegan.
Matter of fact, I don't think very many people at all
should be vegan.
I think meat was for us to eat.
Now, I'm not saying that,
I think everybody's different and everybody's unique.
There's some people that do much better
on a more vegan diet.
And there's people, most of the people that are eating vegan
are eating vegan for philosophical reasons,
not necessarily health reasons.
Now, I know there's a lot of books out there
forks over knife, sent food revolution type books.
I don't know if that book itself is talking about veganism.
But it's unfortunate that when you find out
that these books were sponsored by PETA organizations
or something like that,
the author was paid by an organization
that promotes veganism.
That's political agenda masking as science.
And masking as good exegesis of how our physiology works,
because that's just not true.
There's a lot of people out there on the internet.
I see Instagram videos that people say
we were not created to eat meat.
We were created to eat vegetables.
That's just total nonsense.
We were created to eat meat.
Maybe some people eat too much meat.
Maybe some people don't eat enough meat.
But certainly with cancer,
the reason why I promote meat consumption
with the majority of people that understand
we test people as an individual
and some people we take off meat.
But why I don't think everybody should be vegan,
why I feel very few people should be vegan,
especially in the cancer realm,
is that you need enough protein
in order to make a certain type of white blood cell
that will kill cancer.
So it is the T cells and natural killer cells
that kill cancer cells.
And you need a lot of free amino acids.
The only way you're gonna get that free amino acid content
is to eat enough protein.
And most of the time cancer patients
are already insufficient to their diet
as far as how much they can eat.
They don't feel well.
They might have other comorbidities.
They may have comorbidities from their treatment.
The let's say if they're doing chemotherapy
or immunotherapy, they're not feeling well.
You know, eat what they should be eating.
And they're very often deficient in protein.
In fact, that's one amino acid that a person can have cancer
is low blood protein levels.
So when you have a total protein or albumin levels
and globular levels that are deficient,
that is an albumin assigned for a possible cancer in itself.
So you need to consume enough protein
and you can say, well, we can do that through our vegetables.
We can do that through beans.
We can do that through this.
Well, maybe a healthy person can eat enough.
But you really need to consume your weight,
your desired weight.
So if you've already lost weight from cancer
and you're below your desired weight,
let's say your desired weight is 150 and you're at 135.
You need to eat 150 grams of protein per day.
That's a lot of grams of protein per day.
You can get that in if you eat a few several pieces
of chicken with your other diet.
It's hard to get that in with protein shake
or anything like that.
It's just very difficult to get that in.
You need adequate amounts of protein to do that.
Plus, protein is plenty of red meat can help
with red blood cell formation,
which anemia is another major issue with cancer patients.
So please be aware that a lot of books
that are on the market are not well balanced.
They have an agenda behind them.
They're pushing a certain agenda.
They're pushing a certain philosophy,
which is really a religion.
And it's not the religion that I adhere to.
So I don't think those things
are as much value as some other people put on it.
Question, what do you think of drugs like prilosec
or even taking thumbs?
So I think they're one of the most AIDS light of drugs.
There's a lot of danger.
So I shouldn't say that.
They're very dangerous light of drugs
because why does a person go on prilosec?
Why does a person take role aids or thumbs
because they have indigestion,
because they have, you know,
velcede stomach acid up thisophagus.
They have stomach pain after eating.
They have all the stomach pain.
And 99% of the time they have stomach pain.
And 99% of the time that is from a deficiency
in hydrochloric acid.
So these drugs will remove all the hydrochloric acid
or diminish the hydrochloric acid production in your stomach,
which is exactly the thing you don't want to do.
Well, how can you say that?
It takes my pain away.
So it must be solving the problem.
So when a person doesn't produce enough hydrochloric acid
in their stomach and they eat food,
that food will sit undigested or very partially digested
in the stomach as a bolus of food.
And it doesn't get moved into the small intestine
at the rate that it should,
because it's only very partially digested
because of the hypochlorchidria,
the decreased hydrochloric acid.
And then what stomach acid you do have
could go up into the high point,
the thunders of the stomach,
and you could belch it up.
Most of the time these people also have
a concurrent hyaluronic issue.
So it could go into the esophagus.
It could erode the esophagus.
You could get esophageal ulceration.
You could get stomach ulceration.
And a decreased hydrochloric acid production
over time often leads to multiple things.
We'll need to heal a co-bacter pylori overgrowth.
So you'll have a H pylori infection,
which could cause an enormous amount of health conditions.
You'll have a decrease intrinsic factor production.
That's necessary for you to absorb B12.
So you're going to have a B12 ademia issue.
And it causes ulceration.
So you end up with ulcers in your stomach ulcers
in your esophagus.
And then you take pylosecond,
it relieves your symptoms, and you think you've
solved the problem, but you're actually making it worse.
You're causing a more long-term problem.
You're pretty much guaranteed that you're
going to have an H pylori infection.
So when a person comes in the office,
and they've been a pylosec for any length of time,
it's pretty much a guarantee that they have an H pylori infection.
The problem is, H pyl doesn't always just stay in the stomach.
It doesn't stay in the intestine tract.
So if you do an H pylori breath test, it may show negative.
You do a stool sample test.
It might show negative, too.
So you have to identify it with other factors.
A blood test for H pylori.
It's only a test if it's in the blood right now.
The problem is, H pylori gets under the endothelial
lining of the arteries.
And it's a major component of cardiovascular disease.
So it is a major component.
It is never one cause of stomach cancer.
It's a major component of other cancers.
It could cause skin issues.
It's just a bad player and everything.
And it is the most common bacterial infection of the planet.
That's a statistic I did not make up.
So it is a dangerous thing to be on these things.
Again, when you use medication, or you use herbs,
or natural methods of any kind that just cover up a cause,
you could make a problem a whole lot worse.
So you can't just cover up a cause.
Well, I take private second, it makes my tummy feel better.
If I don't take it, I just can't stay in it.
Well, you've got to fix the cause.
This is just making it worse.
So it's a bad class of drugs, my opinion.
Next, what is the best way to diagnose or to find out
if you have an autoimmune disease or diseases?
There's only one way to find out
if you have an autoimmune disease
and you do antibody testing.
So you could get antibody testing
through your medical clinic that you go to.
But typically, if you go in and say,
I think I have an autoimmune disease
and they have to have some justification
for doing antibody testing, because it's outside
the normal scope of testing.
But if you have a good medical doctor that wants to dig
to find the cause, they might do lupus testing
or something like that.
Now, there's really two different classes of autoimmune disease.
There's systemic autoimmune diseases
that basically can affect multiple cells,
multiple cell lines, multiple tissues.
That's bad, that's not good, right?
And then there's tissue specific autoimmune disease.
So I have antibodies to my thyroid,
with my thyroid, globular antibodies or TPO antibodies,
would be a tissue specific antibody.
So I have antibodies to my thyroid gland.
It's not gonna affect any other tissues,
the autoimmune disease itself is not,
it's only affecting the thyroid.
So, runny antibody panel is the thing to do.
I like Syrex labs.
You could get just a lupus of A and A antibodies
through lab core or something like that or access labs.
But to get some tissue specific antibodies,
you really have to go to more of a specialty lab
as far as cost-wise, to get a entire panel
and the way you order individual things
and it gets more costly.
Syrex array five is a tissue specific antibodies
to more systemic or peripheral tissue antibodies.
Syrex array seven X is more specific to neural tissue,
so brain tissue, which we run a lot of those panels.
And those are very important to run.
So people that may come in and have issues
with cognitive impairment of some kind,
and losing my memory, I don't remember things,
but it's good to run an Alzheimer's panel.
If anything's positive about that,
then we run a Syrex seven X,
which gives more tissue specific to neural tissue.
If you have antibodies to neural tissue,
that's not a good thing.
So if antibodies to any tissue, that's not a good thing.
So again, like I said, the other question,
if you have self-antibodies,
you have a diagnosed autoimmune disease,
everything else, how you learn to treat it,
without the window, you have to treat an autoimmune disease
very differently than you treat any other condition.
And quite honestly, a lot of doctors don't really get that.
So you'll even go to natural doctors that say,
oh, you have chronic Lyme, we're gonna keep you on cat's claw.
Oh, it's a flare again.
It's not in remission anymore.
So we're gonna put you on vitamin C and cat's claw
on this chronic Lyme protocol
that is basically all immune stimulants
in the thought process that we have to kill this Lyme.
It's the Varelia is raised, it's ugly heading in
and it's trying to attack you.
So we have to kill this bacteria.
Well, that can, while that can be true,
the only way to know that is to run a Varelia IgM antibody test
to see if you actually have IgM antibodies
of a courage infection, many times that will be negative
or run a white blood cell panel
and your white blood cell panel are elevated,
then maybe you do need to kill an infection,
an active infection or a lymphocyte panel
where you're gonna get very specific
and you're gonna know whether you have a curative
infection or not.
Most of the time, or I'd say at least many times,
people with chronic conditions like this,
their symptoms, their flare is not
from the infection raising its ugly head again,
it's from destruction of tissue
that would you have antibodies against.
So you might have, you know, we've got a cold or something
that if you just go get, if you catch a cold,
your immune system is gonna flare to kill that cold,
or if your daughter comes home with a strap infection,
your immune system is gonna flare to kill that strap.
But when your immune system flares
and you have an increased cytokine presence
in the blood and in the tissues,
you will create more white blood cells
and to attack that what you have antibodies against.
So if you have antibodies against self tissue,
you're gonna damage more self tissue in that process.
So you do not want to flare your immune system
that's the benefit of taking supplements
that support what are called T regulation cells
or T rag cells, vitamin D is one of those.
People like vitamin D is an immune, you know,
stimulant was really not an immune regulator.
So if your immune system is suppressed,
like you're trying to fight cancer
and your immune system is suppressed,
taking more vitamin D, get your vitamin D levels up,
is beneficial.
If your immune system is hyper vigilant,
in the case of an autoimmune response,
then taking more vitamin D can help bring that down.
So there's some other things on the market
that are beneficial for autoimmune disease
because there are really T reg stimulators.
You do not want to take any immune stimulators.
You want to stimulate T regulation
or cytokine suppression, totally different way to treat that.
So you want to try to diagnose an autoimmune disease.
You got to do antibody testing.
And then if it is positive,
you got to treat it in a totally different fashion
than you've been used to probably treat anything that you know.
So if I don't more on our chronic health
and autoimmune course,
so my arms are all scratched to death
from weeding the raspberries the other day.
Do you have any, oh, here this is the next question.
Do you have any recommendations on level of vitamin D
in the blood that you would recommend for your patients?
Just kind of talked about that.
I am mainly dealing with skin cancer.
A few months ago, my tested level was 24,
which I understand is inefficient.
I get plenty of sunshine daily living in Mexico
and pretty much never supplement for vitamin D, I think.
But in spite of the careful sun,
it takes seems the level is not efficient.
Although I rarely get sick with colds, blues, et cetera,
if the supplement is recommended,
what dose would you suggest to start?
So vitamin D levels of 24, regardless
of whether you have cancer or not, is way too low.
So why would somebody have low vitamin D levels?
Maybe start with that question.
Person would have low vitamin D levels.
Maybe they have a VDR,
that's the receptor for vitamin D.
Maybe they have a VDR gene defect
so that you could have specific vitamin D genes
and you have defects on those genes.
So you don't produce as much vitamin D,
you don't absorb as much vitamin D.
That's one possibility.
So I've had people that are taking 10,000 IU's
of vitamin D daily and they can't get their vitamin D levels
over 35 or something like that.
Well, then you look at their genes and they have a defect
or that gene so they just have to take more.
Number two, a person can have a vitamin D deficiency
because they're on cholesterol or e-drugs.
So 25 hydroxyl cholesterol in the skin
is what is converted to vitamin D
through the act of sunshine.
So if you have a cholesterol, if you're on a cholesterol
or e-drug, it can lower that
and you could end up with difficulty making
vitamin D from sunshine.
Well, you could say, well, if I have to be on this cholesterol
or e-drug, some people may have to be,
that's another bad class of drugs in my opinion.
But if a person feels like they have to be on that drug,
they can always supplement with vitamin D.
It doesn't affect the absorption of vitamin D.
They can also have gut issues.
So if you have inflammatory gut issues,
which you might not even have symptoms of,
that can affect the absorption of vitamin D consumed.
So probably some other thoughts of why a person
would have low vitamin D levels.
But then what do you do about it?
So you have to, you're gonna have to take vitamin D.
So if your vitamin D is 24, if you live in Mexico,
you get plenty of sun, you fall into one of those categories.
And you're gonna have to take vitamin D.
I would start with, yeah, always do something
and then you re-measure, right?
I would start with 5,000, I use a vitamin D per day,
maybe even 10,000, vitamin D is stored.
It's a fat cell, you know, vitamin C.
I don't necessarily need to take it daily.
Some people take 50,000, I use a week.
But I think it's better to take things daily
as far as helping with absorption goes.
So maybe 5,000, I use a week.
It depends on the person's weight.
And then re-measure.
Re-measure your vitamin D levels
and see if that's enough, that's adequate for you.
Again, like I think I said last week or the week before,
when you do blood work and then you do some intervention,
you wanna re-measure to see if your intervention worked, right?
See that over and over again, where that doesn't happen?
Well, I don't think that's good, doctorate.
So, a few more questions here.
My husband has been struggling recently with twitches
in his hands and feet, sore spots around his joints
and in his feet.
He states, his hands and feet go numb.
It is muscles feel weak and he's so tired all the time.
Can this be related to endocrine issues
or to neurology, neurological?
He's a bit of a hypochondriac,
well, for example, let's say it just goes straight
to thinking that he's dying.
He's also suffering from really bad depression and anxiety
and he's been taking an insid drug
because of this for years now.
I don't know what to do or how to help him anymore
or what doctor to go see.
Well, again, okay, here's a symptom.
So the person's having twitches in his hands and feet
and he's an insid drug for depression and anxiety
which, you know, again, there's a person
that depression and anxiety because they have a deficiency
and a medication, you know, I don't think so.
So getting to the cause of this is the root cause
of things is really the way to go.
Unfortunately, it's just not our medical system today.
If you go, if you probably went to a medical doctor
at 60 years old with these symptoms,
most likely you're just gonna get a prescription of something
which I don't think you have a problem
because you have a deficiency in some sort of medication.
It's just the system that we live in
and I don't know if there's really a way to fix that
but find a doctor that doesn't practice that way.
So, yeah, you can contact our office in schedule,
a case review and we can certainly start working through
some of the process of uncovering this
because you gotta start digging.
So as far as the twitching and hands and feet,
what can cause twitching and hands and feet?
Something as simple as, you know,
mineral deficiency, nutritional deficiency.
As we age, many people are eating correctly.
They can have twitching in their hands and feet
can be a neurological issue
or would not say it's an endocrine issue.
It's either neurological or just functional nutritional issue.
If it's bilateral twitching in the hands and feet,
it's probably more than likely a nutritional type thing.
We'd have to dig into it a little bit.
So as far as the anxiety and depression go,
you wanna dig into that a little bit too.
Certainly, inflammation is at a root cause
of a lot of different issues.
You could have inflammation in the gut
that's causing inflammation in the brain
that's causing these things.
Certainly that would tie to the anxiety and depression.
One of your good video to watch is if you go
on our website and you search in the search bar
go to cunnersclinic.com, search in the search bar,
neural inflammation.
I created a video, I think I talked about this a number of weeks back,
but I made a video several years ago
about neural inflammation, in brain inflammation.
And it goes into detail.
You might have to watch the video a couple times
because it goes into detail about your microglial cells
in the brain and what's called a glial private,
which is so, so common.
When a person has anxiety or depression,
that's your first sign, that's your first signal
that you have microglial private.
And you have to start addressing it as early as possible
because that's what leads to microglial private leads
to chronic inflammation in the brain leads to,
which then can lead to antibody production
of neural tissue which is, you know,
can lead to all sorts of brain decline.
And certainly Parkinson's and Alzheimer's disease
are the top of that list for somebody
who's over 60 years old.
If you don't want to, you know, start treating
and early onset dementia,
when you start noticing the dementia signs,
you're, when you want to start treating it
is when you start noticing the peripheral signs of,
you know, anxiety, depression,
they just don't have to drive the hand anymore.
Running those types of tests that we talked about before,
the different antibodies tests,
especially the Cyrex array seven X,
which is the neuronal antibody test
can really save a person's life.
It may not prevent a person from getting dementia,
but it can, you know, if you treat it right,
and you do the action steps,
and the person is willing to be committed
to some of the action steps that I lay out for them,
you can push the dementia out 10 years.
And that makes a big difference.
If you've never experienced a loved one
and your family go through dementia,
you may be little to issue.
It is a big issue when that person,
when you lose your mind
and you lose your ability to really think.
I don't think that, you know, the twitches
in his hands and feet, unless they're acute,
because this has been going on a long time,
I don't think that they're probably not related
to something like breast cancer.
Though, in a key issue, you have to consider that.
If you have acute neurological issues,
like, you know, most times brain cancers diagnosed
by, you know, person having a seizure or something like that.
So they have an acute neurological issue
that they're never had experience of.
But if you have chronic, you know,
issues with twitching the hands and feet,
you start to get inflammatory responses.
So inflammation in neural tissue
can certainly cause that upper motor neuron issues
with in the prefrontal cortex,
in the frontal motor cortex,
what controls that function.
And inflammation in the cerebellum.
So the cerebellum smooths out all your motor function,
motor function that I'm gonna raise my hand.
That's a motor function and contracting the muscle.
But I'm contracting the muscle
that I have, you know, tremors like this.
That's typically a cerebellar function.
Idiot, look at cerebellar antibodies
that cerebellum is the back part of the brain.
That smooths that all out.
So investigating that, finding out what is a cause
is most important thing.
And I think, well, how do that until the day I die?
Is that you don't just treat a symptom.
You figure out what the symptom is trying to tell you.
It's trying to get screaming to you.
Your body is telling you something.
You need to learn to how to listen to the body
and find a doctor that will listen to that
and dig to find some of these causes.
Okay, let's see if any other questions came in.
Remember, you could go to our holistichealthour.com website
and submit your questions there,
then we'll for sure get on it.
If you came in while we were talking,
what is our EMF waves less harmful than X-rays?
Well, most certainly, I would say, yes, you know,
there's, so EMFs are an electromagnetic frequency.
X-rays are also electromagnetic frequency.
So X-ray are extremely damaging to the tissue.
But of course, you have to weigh all that out.
So if I have X-rays that you have to do for my teeth,
what's the rad dose of those X-rays?
But not very high.
So I could probably do, I don't know,
52 X-rays equivalent to one chest X-ray.
Chest X-rays typically, which you compare things to
because as far as an X-ray itself,
a plane, let's call it a plane view X-ray,
which is the old days when you took a X-ray,
you had a X-ray physical X-ray in front of you.
Well, we don't see that so much, we see it's all digital,
but it would always compare to a chest X-ray
because it's about a radiation that was needed
for a chest X-ray.
Well, if you have to go and get two X-rays,
I don't know how many two X-rays are gonna equivalent
rad dose of a chest X-ray.
Compare that to a PET scan or a CT scan.
So let's have to do a CT scan in my lumbar spine
because I hurt my back really bad.
But CT scan is equivalent to about 50 chest X-rays.
So again, it's the rad dose of the radiation
that you're concerned with.
And yeah, EMF radiation is bad too.
So if I'm using my cell phone and I got it up
to my head all the time talking like this,
I never recommend that.
You know that EMFs are going right through your head.
It's the constant use of it.
So what's the rad dose over time?
Is really the question.
So yeah, there's a different issue there.
Question on Facebook.
What's your opinion of people receiving blood transfusions
from people who got the, you know what?
And the blood clots found in the, you know what?
From the, you know what?
New Japanese study on this.
So yeah, we had to address this with our member base
over the last few years.
Some people are much more sensitive to shedding
of those, the spike proteins I myself was one of them
when I was dealing with, well, my cancer was very active
and I was not doing well.
And people came in and they promised they weren't, you know,
vaccinated with the, you know, what shot?
But their husband was or their family
whatever it was and they were with them
and I would get sick.
So I just said that's when we went completely
to nobody's coming in our office.
Everything's at a distance.
It was just better for my health.
And now that I feel like I'm in, you know, remission,
where does that go back to that?
So we've just kind of adapted.
We can see more people across the country
with what we do versus more specifically
to, you know, somebody having to come to our facility.
So everything is at a distance.
So as far as blood transfusions, yeah, that's difficult.
You know, I don't know where you're going to get blood.
If you have to have a blood transfusion,
what are you going to do?
Where are you going to get blood that you know is clean?
As we live in a crazy world, it's just a crazy world.
And totally against the thing that we're talking about
and have been for the very beginning
and probably has lost a whole bunch of viewers.
But I don't care.
So next question, another question came in.
My mom is fighting stage four called a rectal cancer
but she also has Hashimoto's.
You want to stimulate the immune system
and someone with an autoimmune disorder
does this change with types of supplements to use for her cancer?
What a great question.
Boy, you guys are smart.
The answer is yes, it does and know what doesn't.
So it depends on the autoimmune disease
that that person has.
So if it's Hashimoto's and they have breast cancer
and you want to stimulate this person's immune system
to kill the breast cancer cells,
how are you going to balance this out?
Well, to me, cancer trumps the autoimmune disease
in this case because we're not going to die of Hashimoto's
but we could die of breast cancer.
So we have to balance that out.
That's where you have to treat the person with some wisdom.
However, there's lots of things you could do
from an immune standpoint by using key reg stimulator.
Stimulator, so for instance, medicinal mushrooms
are immune stimulants for people
who have a suppressed immune system
but they aren't going to be hyper stimulants
for people who have an autoimmune disease.
So typically, everybody's a little bit different with this
but typically a person with Hashimoto's
can take medicinal mushrooms
and not have any uptake of damage to their thyroid gland.
So there's ways to do it.
Plus, you don't always kill cancer
with just stimulating immune system production.
So back a little bit, does a person have cancer
because they have a suppressed immune system?
Many times no.
So it's not a suppressed immune system
that is always causing cancer.
Now, can that be the case?
Yes, do we have to use some immune booster
sometimes?
Yes, do we always?
No, we don't.
When a person has cancer,
that cancer is in a state of high oxidative stress,
those cancer cells that are replicated
are replicated healthy cells,
that healthy mitochondria,
they're not producing glutathione like they should.
They're near the lethal dose of oxidative stress in the cell.
So one of the major ways that we use to help kill cancer
is, well, first of all, we use rife technology,
which is not immune stimulated at all.
It's killing the cancer directly
and stimulating immune attack on the cancer
and giving you know, that tip over a fact
of the oxidative stress to the cancer cell.
But the way chemotherapy works to club cancer
is creating more oxidative stress in the body
that's going to create more oxidative stress
in the cancer cell,
tip it over to its lethal dose and kill the cancer cell.
That's how chemotherapy literally works.
Well, we do that a lot with a lot of the cancer nutrients.
So you use higher dose vitamin C,
even like a zomal vitamin C.
Certainly at IV vitamin C,
use a laotryl type B17, use a protocell.
There's many of the therapies that we use
that are not immune stimulated per se,
they're oxidative.
So they're created greater amount of oxidative stress
in the cancer cell.
And thereby tipping it over its lethal dose
and killing the cancer that way.
So you don't always have to, you have to be careful.
You have to be more careful treating a cancer patient
when the cancer patient also has a concurrent autoimmune disease.
Now, there's certain autoimmune diseases
that are more serious with that.
If a person has auto antibodies to myelin sheath cells,
which we see commonly these days,
then you really have to be careful stimulating the immune response
because if I do that, you're created a demilinated disease,
which is very serious.
So it's, yeah, there is different ways that you treat it
with knowing that the person has a comorbidity
of an autoimmune disease that's completely unrelated to the cancer.
So great question.
Okay, we are at our time.
I thank you for being a part of it.
We're a member to go to holistichealthour.com
where Dustin does a great job of categorizing all these videos
and putting a lot of text to them
so you could read what time frame you want to get on
and jump onto past videos,
but a lot of past videos, very well archived.
Also go to contestclinic.com where you could access
our courses, they're super cheap, no nonsense.
You got to take the course.
So there's no reason for you to be ignorant.
The Bible says, I do not wish you to be ignorant
and my children perish for lack of knowledge.
Now it's knowledge in the Lord that we're talking about,
that he's talking about there,
but I think it's general knowledge too.
You know, we're not supposed to use this brain that we have, right?
And use the studies that other people did have done.
And so you take our courses, you learn a lot from them
and the more you can study, show yourself a proof,
you're doing the right thing,
you can help other people, you can help your family.
I think we have a responsibility there.
Go to contestclinic.com,
you could see all our blog posts.
Like I said, there's well over 1,000 of them.
You could go to our YouTube channel
and our videos.com.tuttersclinic.com channel too.
I don't know, 1,500 videos make use of these resources.
Those are all three, okay?
So thank you, have a blessed day.
I'll be praying for all of you
wherever to get your questions in for next week.
Bye-bye.